news reader is one of my favorite  typefaces  it's not only a charming serif with lots  of usability it's also free in google  fonts  by the way google fonts is not the same  as designers remember from its launch in  2010 its revamp in 2011 or in 2016.  today google fonts has nearly 181  variable fonts newsreader is one of them  it was made by productiontype who has  made fonts for the wnba renault and  ubisoft  from extra light to extra bold roman to  italic 6 point to 72 point screen text  you can use it anywhere  you could just use the 42 static fonts  of newsreader but google fonts lets you  use it as a variable font and that means  it has an unlimited number of typestyles  so you can customize how any text looks  between six different axes which is why